je ne suis qu'un simple personnage de
moins dans ma propre vie parfois je me
dis que j'aimerais bien en devenir le
héros et personnages je connais jean
peuple mes livres en général d'ailleurs
les histoires se construisent avec
autour d'eux à partir de plus les
personnages on en croise partout dans la
rue il ya des gens dont on dit celui-là
c'est un personnage personnage sa vie ta
m ça peut faire preuve de profondeur
l'originalité c'est une particularité
aussi un personnage en général ça meurt
dans son lit on dans le lit de quelqu'un
d'autre qui est une ville et pas
toujours désagréable d'ailleurs face off
pour la personne dans le lit duquel on
est en train de mourir mais en tout cas
c'est quelque chose de relativement
maîtrisé les héros c'est autre chose
compte il de plus que moi ou
plus exactement ont-ils de moins
on devient un héros parce qu'on le
désire ou parce que les circonstances
nous y oblige
mais en général ça veut dire renoncer à
quelque chose
laisser quelque chose abandonné quelque
chose ça veut dire qu'on franchit une
porte qui se referme derrière vous et on
se retrouve tout seul alors essayez le
léger c'est certain qu'on court plus
vite on se bat plus fort qu'on va plus
loin on se forge au feu de ses propres
passions on devient en s'incarne dans
ses propres désirs on devient une espèce
de deux sabres trempé dans sa propre
volonté
on est intouchable on devient
littéralement hors de portée je ne suis
pas un héros
faut pas croire ce que disent les
journaux comme disait balavoine je peux
vous le chantez si vous voulez mais moi
je ne le suis pas encore et je ne suis
pas sûr d'ailleurs que j'ai tellement
envie de le devenir parce que c'est
quand même quelque chose de profondément
effrayant cette métamorphose quand on y
réfléchit
par contre j'ai vu quelques-uns des
personnages de mes livres devenir des
héros y en a certains que j'ai forcé que
j'ai poussé savoir que dans les héros de
vos livres
il ya un certain nombre de désigné
volontaire quelqu'un que vraiment le
l'écrivain à coups de cravache a forcé
jouer lé rôle mais il y en a aussi qui à
un moment donné se dresse sur la page et
10 à partir de maintenant je prends les
choses en charge alors il peut vous le
faire façon konan vous savez si c'est le
héros grand costaud baraqué et c'est
très bien
ils peuvent vous le faire aussi
quelquefois de manière toute douce et
timide façon sam gamegie vous savez le
personnage du seigneur des anneaux
quand il dit je ne peux pas porter la
noue à votre place mais
frodon je peux vous portez vous et à ce
moment là c'est lui qui prend l'histoire
sur ses épaules et c'est lui qui fait
avancer l'histoire
c'est pas toujours quelqu'un qu'on a
prévu
c'est même pas à quelqu'un à qui on a
donné un rôle particulier ça peut être
un simple comparses
c'est juste que dans le feu de l'action
il s'est forgé et il a dit à partir de
maintenant le héros c'est moi c'est une
expérience qui arrive à beaucoup
d'écrivains
croyez moi on en parle entre nous ça
fait partie des choses que vous
entendrez dire mais c'est vrai ça s'est
produit
c'est une expérience absolument
fascinante
en même temps c'est le début des
emmerdements selimi l'environnement
parce qu'on a un magnifique plan sur le
mur bain ajouté
on a construit un beau château c'est du
sable s'effrite
on n'a plus rien on n'a plus de
direction n'a plus d'horizon
on a juste quelqu'un là qui est la cas
d'ibr à partir maintenant je me démerde
est finie on peut même plus dire qu'on a
plus de garde-fous il ya même plus de
route
on se retrouve dans la jungle avec un
simple stylo comme machette mais à
partir de là il faut tracer
le personnage lui il avance faut savoir
que la différence entre un personnage
est un héros si vous voulez c'est
imaginer un hamster que vous mettez dans
une cage le hamster qui se met dans la
cage la cage de l'histoire et crème dans
la petite roue commence à faire tourner
une petite route en taille descend
manger des graines
il remonte faire tourner sa petite roue
il mène une vie longue et heureuse c'est
ça un personnage dans une histoire
en général on sait comment finissent les
hamsters c'est à peu près comment la
manière dont finissent les personnages
dans les histoires quelquefois on
rajoute un deuxième hamster et ça fait
une fin heureuse
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas un
héros c'est quelqu'un qui fait exploser
la cage qui démonte tribuil la petite
roue qui fabrique un radeau et qui part
sur l'océan une fois qu'il est sorti du
cocon bas et nous en derrière cavale on
trace les personnages on arrive encore à
les maîtriser mais les héros l'hérault
s'est totalement imprévisible ça n'en
fait qu'à sa tête et ça a toujours un
coup d'avancé sur vous alors croyez-moi
quand on écrit on n'est plus en
situation de retenir les rênes en étant
situation née cramponner à l'arrière du
carrosse et on a le cheval qui part tout
seul
et donc on est face à quelqu'un qui a
une espèce de pouvoirs magiques
étonnant il sait ce qu'il fait on le
sait pas nous on est écrivain on est
derrière on a un personnage qui d'un
seul coup vous a dit t'occupes je gère
et je n'en sais pas plus que toi j'ai
juste cette espèce de convictions
totalement profonde que je suis à la
bonne place que je fais ce qu'il ya à
faire ça c'est un sentiment un petit peu
magique on se dit qu'un qu'est ce qui
lui prend alors moi je suis là je suis
en train d'écrire mon histoire quand
même qui a besoin d'avancer parce que si
jamais je ne fait pas avancer l'histoire
si jamais mon héros rentreront dans le
rang ça veut dire que l'histoire va
gagner l'histoire va gagner ça veut dire
que le mécanisme
l'histoire va broyer mes personnages les
personnages y sont dans les petits
troubles dans le la cage en forme
d'aquarium et le l'histoire va les
étouffer sous son propre poids
de temps en temps un personnage arrive à
être un petit grain de sable de
l'histoire mais celui qui détourne
l'histoire celui qui la cravache celui
qui l'a fait aller là où il veut c'est
le héros
sauf que moins évidemment gse espèce de
truc qui a surgi sur ma page et qui
véritablement force mais doit écrire ce
qu'il doit faire et je m'inquiète parce
que croyez moi c'est très effrayant
c'est très inquiétant
donc je les interroge de temps en temps
je suis devant mon écran je me dis mais
qu'est ce que tu fais pourquoi vas tu là
pourquoi tu décidé ça pourquoi est-ce
que tu t'intéresses à cette fille est
pas à la magnifique princesse que
j'avais mis sur ton chemin
pourquoi le héros ne me réponds jamais
lui il avance son boulot c'est d'avancer
c'est de faire les choses d'ailleurs
quand on y réfléchit
les justifications c'est pour les
historiens c'est pas vraiment pour les
conquérants le résultat c'est quand même
que on a quelqu'un à l'arrière de sa
tête qui prend toutes les décisions et
ça devient de plus en plus effrayant
jusqu'à un moment donné où ce sentiment
d'être complètement perdus au milieu
d'une page on a quand même écrit
soi-même devient tellement tellement
terrifiant tellement bizarre qu'on lève
les doigts du clavier c'est un truc
qu'on fait on lève les dos du clavier
l'histoire s'arrête alors à prendre un
café
quelquefois reprendre deux cafés
quelquefois en corse le café quelques
fois mais même pas de café dans le
whisky mais on va faire quelque chose et
à l'arrière-plan de votre tête là bas
derrière à l'endroit où se passe des tas
de choses intéressantes et où on n'ira
jamais il ya mon héros qui fait laissons
pas qui s'impatientent qui est gpac
aiguise son épée qui vous dit bon ça va
être à moi là
et parce qu'il a raison parce qu'on en
saura jamais plus eh ben on remet les
doigts sur le clavier et on se force à
écrire quelque chose et le héros vous
dites inquiètes je t'amène en voyageant
avec mes roues si j'ai quand même pas
mal voyagé avec eux j'ai fait des beaux
voyages des voyages tout à fait
inattendue mais des beaux voyages
j'en suis ressorti tout cabossé mais
c'était quand même des beaux voyages
j'ai quand même appris deux trois
petites choses qui me serviront
peut-être un jour si l'occasion se
présente
apprendre comment on devient la première
chose peut-être la plus importante celle
apprendre à voyager léger
c'est à dire abandonner bon ce qu'on
possède ça c'est facile laissé son
téléphone portable dans la loge et et
venir à poil c'est faisable mais aussi
abandonner ses certitudes
la certitude c'est bien ça tient chaud
c'est vachement confortable ça protège
de tout un tas de choses des certitudes
vous avez d'autres certitudes balancé
par les gens qui rebondissent sur les
vôtres et vous regardez 1-0 même pas mal
c'est bien les certitudes mais en même
temps ça finit par faire une espèce de
couche un peu gourde
ça fait bizarre d'homme on n'avance pas
bien avec des certitudes donc tout ça ça
tombe d'ailleurs moi-même quand j'écris
mais quand je me retrouve dans cette
situation là la première chose que je
fais ça paraît bizarre c'est je me
déshabille je me déshabille et j'essaye
de maigrir parce que maigrir aiguise les
dents bon je suis d'accord
vous voyez pas de profil m'enfin ça
m'est pas arrivé déjà d'un certain temps
je suis d'accord mais ça m'est arrivé
ça m'est arrivé ça m'arrivera j'espère
encore et je serais même pas obligé de
prendre du charbon de bois ou des
couffins pour que ça se produise quelque
fois mon héros me forcera à le faire
d'accord et je me retrouvais vous avez
ce film 37 2 le matin où vous avez le
personnage qui tape à la machine il est
nu est vraiment dans le plus simple
appareil et raconte son histoire
simplement parce qu'il est collé à
l'histoire il est allé au contact
il ne supporte même pas la moindre chose
sur lui pourquoi ce qu'on le supporte
pas parce que on a tendance à l'oublier
et on l'oubli parce que sinon ce serait
terrible d'y penser mais on vit tous en
état s'y enfermer dans une espèce de
camisoles qu'on traîne depuis depuis
qu'on est bébé quelque chose qui nous a
été imposée par la société par la
circonstance par les gens qui nous
aiment
quelque chose aussi qu'on a appris à
aimer nous mêmes on s'est enfermés dans
des couches et des couches et des
couches de protection dhabi et c'est à
quand les biens bains hérault
c'est quelqu'un qui supporte pas ça qui
se déshabillent littéralement et qui
finit d'ailleurs par par casser ces
armures qui enlève tout ça donc un héros
ça voyage léger quand un héros a gagné
quand il repart avec le sac d'or et la
princesse sous le bras vous pourrez
tranquille que l'épisode d'après l'or a
été dépensé depuis longtemps et la
princesses oubliées dans un des ports
loin loin loin et dont on n'entendra
jamais plus parler c'est juste c'est pas
que on n'est pas contents de la voir
c'est juste que c'est fait pour être
abandonné ces choses là donc on voyage
léger y compris de ses certitudes y
compris de ses ongles mort un héros ne
peut pas renoncer à ce qu'il ait alors
été obligé de renoncer à ce qu'il
possède au fur et à mesure
la deuxième chose c'est de ne jamais
détourné les yeux de ne jamais esquivé
quand vous avez quelque chose vous êtes
en train d'écrire votre histoire une
scène se prépare elle n'est pas agréable
vous allez tuer un personnage que vous
aimez bien c'est une chose que beaucoup
d'écrivains ont fait on est des années
des psychopathes
sauf que on tue des gens étudiants à qui
on s'attache des gens qui ont vécu dans
notre tête il ya des gens que l'on tue
avec miséricorde
parce qu'on les aime profondément mais
leur mort on a eu beau essayer elle est
devenue inévitable et donc ces choses là
c'est celle-là on détourne pas les yeux
on les affronte parce que sinon le livre
est amputé le livre et castrés et
l'histoire ne pousse pas comme elle le
devrait en plus il ya quelque chose
qu'un compositeur qui s'appelle john
cage a dit c'est si un bruit vous
dérange
écoutez le l'importance à écouter le ca
veut pas dire esquiver le bouchez vous
les oreilles ça veut dire prenez le
entendez le décomposer les allées
l'analyse et allez vous battre contre
lui s'il le faut ou l'apprivoiser si
vous en êtes capables mais l'important
c'est aller au contact
mes personnages et mes héros ne détourne
jamais les yeux n'esquive pas quand il
ya un endroit où aller quand il ya quand
une bagarre quand il ya un bordel quand
y'a un truc désagréable affaire ben ils
y vont parce qu'après tout c'est leur
boulot et j'essaie de faire commun est
la dernière chose qui est importante que
m'ont appris mes héros c'est de
justement de faire confiance cette
partie de moi qui ne raisonnent pas mais
qui sait celle qui est à l'arrière-plan
de maths est celle qui dans mes tripes
me dit cette personne là que je ne
connais pas il va falloir que j'aille la
rencontre et qui me dit c'est dans cette
espèce de déviation qui a l'air bizarre
que les choses vont se passer
vous savez le sentiment que l'histoire
commence là bas mais on ne sait pas
pourquoi mais on y va ça j'ai appris à
faire confiance cette partie là et
je me dis ça m'a permis de faire
quelques unes des plus belles
découvertes de ma vie alors est-ce que
ça suffit c'est trois choses voyager
léger ne pas détourner les yeux se faire
confiance en théorie oui pour elle c'est
qu'en théorie il n'y a pas de différence
entre la théorie à la pratique il en
pratique et donc j'aimerais bien être
capable de vous proposez vous savez on
va dire un système en douze leçons vous
savez comme se désintoxiquer pour les
alcooliques anonymes
on aurait 12 étapes j'arriverai je vous
dirais bonjour on irait bonjour je
rappelle jean clottes
bonjour jean claude je mène une vie tout
à fait quelconque mais je me soigne très
bien jean claude et onfray 12 étapes
comme ça et on sortirait libérer du
quotidien et à ce moment là
chaque instant serait une aventure en
sortirait dans la rue et ce serait le
décor de nos prochaines vie ce serait
merveilleux
ça marche pas je regrette qu'il n'y a
pas de mode d'emploi
il n'y a rien d'aussi net aussi défini
et quand la réalité décide de nous
transformer en héros elle le fait sans
nous demander notre avis et sans nous
prévenir à l'avancé
alors on peut se contenter de vivre
comme un personnage mais avec un bagage
léger avec des yeux qui regardent avec
un sentiment quand même que l'on peut
être prêt parce que comme ça quand le
chevalier arrivera en me disant viens
allons combattre le dragon je regarderai
pas j'irai pas désolé à trois heures
j'ai piscine
je dirais ok allons-y et si je fais ça
ça veut dire que tous les matins je peux
me réveiller face à une journée qui
s'annonce comme une aventure et le soir
quand je me couche je peux écrire les
quelques phrases de l'épopée de ma vie
et sourire juste avant de m'endormir